i wanted to check in because recently
the world economic forum happened and
i'm not going to play the whole thing
because it's too long
but i do you want to see some highlights
from the world economic forum
some big stuff sure some real big stuff
what's going on i'm lily and this is the
davos daily your go
what it's the world economic forum huh
what's the problem with the world what
what what do you think of when you think
of the world economic forum
well indians i guess yeah that doesn't
make sense
what's going on i'm lily and this is why
did she
dress like a fly girl i'm so annoyed by
her dress
i don't understand what she's dressed on
she looks like she shops exclusively at
a
thrift store you know it's probably like
a 7 000 outfit too
but this is what we're talking about
they buy stuff that's supposed to look
like old and shitty but they pay like
seven thousand dollars for it
davos daily your go-to source for the
biggest highlights of the davos agenda
okay agenda good i like a generic words
like agenda that's a good word it makes
you feel comfortable right
when somebody walks up to you and they
say they have an agenda you immediately
relax
by the way you're good you guys are no
reason stop being
yeah also we want to lay out this agenda
this world
economic agenda
when public health issues become
politically
charged like wearing a mask or not
becomes a political statement
you cannot imagine how destructive that
is
well it's only political because you're
forcing people
it wouldn't be political if you gave
them an option do you see the difference
here
if you were to say look we recommend
like the surgeon general recommends you
don't smoke
but you don't stop people from smoking
you know
you're not gonna stop you i mean yeah
rice but have you tried not being in
i have but you know what happens they
call me anyway mike
okay yeah true so i mean what are you
gonna do
it's a political statement you cannot
imagine how
destructive that is to any unified
public health message i completely agree
wearing a mask is not political it's
responsible
but the moment that you're forcing
people it becomes my article
oh god i hate her and listen
she completely agrees so look we have
two brilliant people fauci and lily
singh
telling you they agree are you gonna go
against science
and a toronto street [ __ ] i hate i
hate that i have to
god damn it i really hate that i have to
defend lily sing here but somebody in
the chat saying that she's fat fat fat
she's not she wears terrible clothes
that don't fit her well yeah
she wears tear like i i would say this i
don't think lily sings in bang in shape
like i don't think she's hitting the gym
every day she's not f especially by
american standards i wouldn't say she's
no she's like she's a little boxy yeah
she doesn't she has a weird body but
i wouldn't say she's fat and she would
also wears
terrible clothes like that wouldn't be
flattering even if a chick was in shape
wearing a mask is not political it's
responsible also i break out all the
time and amass covers it it's a win-win
women in particular have been badly
affected by job losses
and extra burdens of care we also see
fragility in the climate
and biodiversity crisis and i would like
is to uh really underscore
uh the fact that the people who are
against our agenda
that we are laying out are and we will
not tolerate zinc
wait wait no for
us to have an agenda
can you stop rolling out evil germans
and telling me i'm gonna
like you stop gaslighting me bro yeah
those are existential threats and those
are getting worse
we are waging war on nature and
destroying our life
yeah we might be waging war on nature
but we're [ __ ] winning
guess what buddy this ain't gonna be
vietnam we're gonna win
[ __ ] your polar bears fourth system and
nature is striking back
obviously mother nature is striking back
if my indian mom has taught me anything
is that a mother will put you
do you have another mom that i don't
know about because that's your indian
mom that was a really
uh that was a really unnecessary
um adjective right like i would be like
oh yeah my irish mother
it's not her swedish mom but you see how
obviously she
how badly she needs to work it in even
when it's not needed like
just your mom just your mom's fine i'm
looking at you
i can tell she's indian we figured it
out could you imagine like your your
friend like
you know the couple that you guys know i
want to say that yeah would you imagine
if
if she just kept saying that oh yeah
yeah yeah okay i know i was just talking
the other day to my indian mom and she
was telling me like that i was like yeah
i know she's indiana so we went out with
her anniversary i want to do something
nice for him so i took my indian mom and
my
i know they're indian and uh guess what
we had
indian food no olive garden what are you
[ __ ] racist
what's wrong with you why would you just
decide
i walked right into it face first god
damn it cat just running into a sliding
glass door just
you know like i'll see you there's a
door there
i will say that my indian friend she did
i will quote her
the whitest indian girl you've ever seen
but
she she goes yeah i've been to india eat
pray love is full of [ __ ]
i was like fair enough taught me
anything is that a mother will put you
in your place
so check out my gold greta tell it like
it is today we hear nations
ah hello i'm
that's a disturbing one it's an
unfortunate looking child
we hear nations and leaders all over the
world speak of an
exercise like if i had a daughter and
this was my daughter i'd be like [ __ ]
right like you know like on the one like
you don't want for for instance like you
don't want to have a like a hot daughter
because then that's like they hit high
school middle school age and your life's
a
[ __ ] disaster you're literally
paranoid 24 hours a day you're afraid
they're gonna fall in with the
with the what a joy read called the more
cultural crowd cultural crime um
there's so many things that go wrong if
you have a daughter who's like
popular cool and hot and like a
cheerleader you're [ __ ]
so when you have a daughter like this
there is the disappointment aspect of
like
ah this was the best my jeans could have
done
put on the other hand you're like at
least i have to worry about my daughter
coming home pregnant
like there's no no running backs they're
gonna be running train on my daughter
and in the [ __ ] locker room
so there's that at least my kid's just
gonna like
play magic the gathering and smell like
pee i guess that's
you know what i haven't you know what i
have enjoyed about covid
is that people really stopped talking
about her nobody cared about her for a
long time
nobody cared about any of this
existential climate emergency and yet
instead of taking the immediate action
you would in any emergency
they set up vague hypothetical distant
targets
way into the future targets based on
loopholes
and incomplete i hate her weird cadence
of like
like you do realize the reason why we
all hate greta is because
nobody wants to be condescended to
and nobody wants to be like given a
[ __ ]
condescending morality lesson by a child
nobody wants to be talked down to by a
kid first of all nobody wants to be
talked down to by a woman
secondly nobody wants to be talked down
to by a kid and you're bringing me a
teenage girl to talk down to me like
like in my family if if a girl this age
was going around talking to people like
this they would have gotten
cracked right in the [ __ ] mouth uh
loopy
luck has said she's not a kid anymore
you could pick on her i'm sorry
let me just i don't know you understand
the show we were picking on her when she
was a kid
too yeah it doesn't really matter here
yeah the moment you want to play with
the big boys you just
you're gonna get treated yeah i'll point
your [ __ ] pregnant wife's stomach and
make fun of your unborn baby i don't
give a [ __ ] there's no time limit
yep hypothetical distant targets
way into the future targets based on
loopholes
and incomplete numbers okay cool i'll
tell you what
greta i have a great idea
why don't you go to china and go [ __ ]
tell them what to do yeah go tell china
go
go tell the go tell the ancestors of uh
this goofy [ __ ] whose video you're in
yeah tell indians go tell go tell go
over there
and tell them what they're doing is
wrong instead of the people that
actually are really for the most part
recycle
and do the best that they can yeah say
what you want about fracking
and slurry ponds and all the [ __ ] that
we do
um with all this crap like in america
but
like china just dumps their cold water
like
right into the ocean like they don't
even there is they don't even make like
a landfill they just go oh no just
on plastic and ocean that so talk to
them
because at least at least we don't have
just one giant pipe
that just outflows into the pacific
ocean for all of america's [ __ ] like
china does
china's like what is it nuclear throw it
in the ocean oh is it oil throat in here
whatever whatever it is throw it
everything in the ocean
targets like net zero emissions net zero
i used to have that that's the free
internet service it would have ads but
it works
15. targets that equal surrender
every time i lose faith in humanity i
look at people like greta
and my faith gets restored
please i don't need somebody that's in a
ted bedroom mansion that has a bigger
carbon footprint than like 30 people
telling other telling normies that
they're the problem
that's the issue with all of this
climate change stuff it's not just that
lily singh has a mansion because she
does
have but listing has another mansion
that she broadcast her show from
she doesn't do her show from her mansion
she does it from another mansion where
they probably used to film
set that's two double mansions we get a
mansion i mean we can
we broke a mansion if we would have
invested in game stop we could have well
we just rent
rent a mansion let's say you should rent
okay right and then what they say right
they said rent and lease rent and lisa
financial guy i'll tell you that just
rent it it's fine you don't want to own
anything
[Laughter]
thankfully greta's not alone and things
don't have to stay this way they do
there is a very strong awareness
by people my thing is too hey lily and
everybody in general human race can we
stop saying
faith in humanity restored can we stop
saying that for it's so overused and
it's like
literally somebody will be like this
five-year-old tweeted about climate
change
faith in humanity restored and you're
like
okay it's not like that that phrase used
to be reserved for like uh
uh we'd see like a local news story
where it's like
members of the crips and bloods ran into
a burning house to save a firefighter
today who was injured
that's like one of those things where
you go oh wow faith in humanity
a bunch of gang bangers helped the guy
because he was burning alive
nowadays it's just like this kid tweeted
propaganda that his teacher told him
wow faith in humanity restored
question here why have they talking
about climate change is the president of
the european central bank gonna speak
because the great
reset but okay so
all right so the ozone remember the
ozone that was the thing and then they
stopped talking about that
they fixed it i guess apparently they
use flex seal
they the way the the climate change so
white people white supremacy let's start
okay talk about this all right i'm
listening i'm
i'd like to see where this is going so
we're gonna have
some sort of like um like a a reset
like um i i don't i don't want to say
new world order because it just sounds
too on the nose got it so we're gonna go
with re
so we're gonna do a reset which means
that you're not allowed to have
money or job anymore your job is going
to be replaced by a robot
and you're just going to sit at home and
eat uber eats collect universal basic
income
and die childless are you following me
i mean i am but i'm worried about this
well if you get in the way of our agenda
we're going to have this german
gentleman call you
why do you keep seeing agenda that makes
it worse for me
a german fellow okay well i apologize
then
this is all very confusing the world is
very like
i know the the hack joke is like you
know the guy like when trump won
everybody's like could you imagine being
like the guy that's just been in a coma
for five years and you wake up and
you're like wait what happened but like
seriously now imagine being a guy that's
been in a coma for five years
you missed trump you missed cohort you
missed great reset you missed
the george floyd riots you missed vegas
you missed all this stuff
you just wake up and you're going all
right how much time you got
are you awake it's gonna take a while to
explain
everything that's happened at that point
i should be like can you please put me
back under i i don't really
need this wait a minute
are calling us nazis and i have to
not drive a car anymore because this kid
said so and
jesus yeah just can you put me back into
the coma
thank you is that an option must be
dealt
with as a matter of priority more than
70
in 16 largest countries want climate
change and the fight against it
to be the priority unions already knew
that ah
yeah if you sure if i got out of a coma
and you showed me like a five minute
montage video of the past five years
i would literally i would go
[Laughter]
okay dude that's good that's [ __ ]
good
how long you've been working on that
video like the whole time i was in the
coma
that's [ __ ] that's brilliant no
seriously take me to a restaurant let's
go to a bar and everybody's going
ah don't tell me it's no you don't
everything you saw in that video
let him have a meal and let him just
[ __ ] enjoy it for a little bit
and it's like no it's illegal i'm sorry
they put guns in our [ __ ] now
you've been out of the loop crisis we
faced
before the pandemic hit the climate
emergency history
levels of inequality driving exclusion
anger and despair wait i'm sorry
all these riots are because of climate
change
you didn't know this i thought it was
for
racial equality or whatever but i guess
it's no it's that it's climate change
yeah it's climate change bro
so we've got choices now will people
be at the forefront with their
environment of a new social
contract or will we see businesses
social contract
yes royce are you paying attention but i
don't want to get into any sort of
business agreement with you people
you're [ __ ] vultures
so this quake is very important she's
got my vote
if ever it needed something you don't
get to vote in her country you don't get
to vote in their agenda
wait i'm sorry you don't get a vote in
this country you're canadian
twice i'm gonna be real with you if
you're like me sometimes hearing all
this stuff can feel overwhelming and you
don't know what to do but the thing is
if
you're if you're like stupid yeah i get
it if you're dumb idiot
yeah all do something it's so important
now more than ever
i mean the thing is like i'm dumb too
but um
but then i don't like just when when a
bunch of sinister creepy germans come to
me and ask me to push their agendas i
just don't do it
because i'm dumb and i'm like i don't
know i don't know if i should be telling
people
that uh uh cutting their kid's penis off
is good
maybe i should just stay out of it yeah
just leave me out man
and to act that's just a taste of what
we've got in store for you
and there's so much more exciting keep
yourself in the loop each day with the
davos daily
i'm in on youtube that's right subscribe
to this globalist
propaganda funded by the world economic
forum
uh does you know and i i've asked this
question a thousand times but
really like do these people ever have a
moment
even a moment where they just are like
sitting there eating breakfast and
like think about the people they're in
bed with like does this ever occur to
these people that you
wouldn't like wouldn't you be just like
sitting there like eating breakfast in
the morning and like it would pop in
your head and you'd be like jesus christ
like
that meeting i had with those people
were
pretty evil he felt pretty evil right i
think they've convinced i think a lot of
them have convinced himself they're
doing the right thing